Estados Unidos y Taiwán estrechan sus
lazos con un acuerdo comercial el
propósito fortalecer y profundizar la
relación económica entre los dos países
lo que llevó a una respuesta inmediata
de China que considera a la isla
Autónoma de Taiwán parte de su
territorio Beijing ha advertido sobre
represalias
Estados Unidos debe de tener todas las
formas de interacción oficial con Taiwán
no debe negociar ni firmar acuerdos con
implicaciones soberanas o de carácter
oficial ni enviar señales equivocadas a
las fuerzas separatistas taiwanesas En
nombre del comercio
descrito por el gobierno de Taiwán como
el acuerdo comercial más completo
firmado con Washington desde 1979 el
pacto tiene como objetivo agilizar
controles aduaneros mejorar los
procedimientos regulatorios y establecer
medidas anticorrupción el acuerdo
también permite a Taiwán abrirse a más
exportaciones estadounidenses Estados
Unidos ya es el segundo socio comercial
más grande de Taiwán el año pasado el
valor total de su comercio de bienes
ascendió a 136.000 millones de dólares
Washington también se ha mantenido como
un Aliado clave y proveedor de armas
para la isla a pesar de cambiar el
reconocimiento diplomático de taipei a
Beijing en 1979 Los Defensores del
acuerdo dicen que así aumentará la
capacidad de Taiwán para resistir la
coerción económica de China